All right.
We have gotten to the point where the president
of the United States in what is obviously
a desperate and crazed sort of last ditch
effort to try to make the case that he's not
obviously violating the emoluments clause
of the constitution is now calling the emoluments
clause to the constitution in and of itself
phony.
That's his word, not mine.
Now, as you may know, Donald Trump has endlessly
been clearly violating the emoluments clause.
I will redefine what that clause is for you
momentarily.
Just so we're all on the same page.
Uh, the strategy from Trumpists has been first
to deny that he's violating the emoluments
clause that has mostly failed since he so
obviously and brazenly continuing to violate
the emoluments clause to the constitution.
Then they shifted to pretending that the emoluments
clause to the constitution, uh, is part of
the constitution, but not really.
Like it's sort of this appendage to the constitution.
It's an irrelevant vestige of sorts.
It doesn't really matter.
Of course, that's also not true.
Either we value the constitution or we don't.
Either the value of the constitution is complete
or it is not.
And you can't pick and choose when it is and
is not worthy or deserved of being adhere
to.
And now Donald Trump is straight up saying,
including to his supposedly constitutional
conservative followers that the Amal humans
clause is phony.
A Trump spoke to the media yesterday, including
about trying to have the [inaudible] at his
personal club Doral, a plan which has since
been canceled by the way, because it also
would be an obvious violation of the emoluments
clause to the constitution.
Trump was asked about it and he said, you
people with this phony emoluments clause,
other presidents, if you look, other presidents
were wealthy, not huge wealth.
George Washington was actually considered
a very, very rich man at the time, but they
ran their business as George Washington.
They say he had two desks, he had a presidential
desk and a business desk.
I don't think you people with dystonia monuments
laws.
And by the way, uh, I would say that it's
cost me anywhere from two to $5 billion to
be precedent.
And that's okay between, uh, what I lose and
what I could have made.
You'll notice there Donald Trump also defending
a president, being president and running a
business while being president of the United
States and in so doing casually equating himself
to George Washington.
It's, it's interesting that there are so many
other crazy things that he says in that 31
second clip that equating himself to George
Washington is not even the primary thing that
we are talking about like that.
That's how outrageous the status quo is.
Uh, it's time for a reality check.
The emoluments clause is the constitution.
It's article one, section nine and it says,
no title of nobility shall be granted by the
United States and no person holding any office
of profit and trust under them shall without
the consent of Congress, except of any present
emoluments office or title of any kind, whatever
from any King, Prince or foreign state.
That's the constitution of the United States.
Article one section nine.
It's not the only relevant emoluments related
portion of the constitution.
We also have article two section one which
says, the president shall at stated times
receive for his services a compensation which
shall neither be increased nor diminished
during the period for which he shall have
been elected and he shall not receive within
that period any other emoluments from the
United States or any of them.
So what do the constitutional conservatives
say about this?
Trump meant phony as a metaphor maybe.
I don't know.
I haven't heard any defenses yet because I
think increasingly the constitutional conservatives
are pretending that they never really wanted
Trump to be president anyway, and Oh, what
me vote for Trump?
No, I don't remember what I did in November
of 2016 if there's one thing that won't be
able to be said once this nightmare is over
and hopefully that nightmare is over in 15
months, although it could be four years and
15 months, we will not be able to say that
people simply had no idea what Donald Trump
was doing because he's telling us, he's saying
that running a business while being president
is fine.
He's telling us that he sees inconvenient
parts of the constitution as phony.
This is actually once again impeachable.
What I mean by that is violating the Amal
humans clause endlessly.
That is impeachable and that's been going
on for two and a half years, however long
it's been at this point, the publicly calling
of the emoluments clause, phony is also in
and of itself impeachable because Donald Trump's
swore an oath to uphold the constitution and
he's publicly saying that there's a piece
of the constitution which he swore to uphold
on a Bible.
Remember he's saying, well, there's a part
of that constitution that not only am I not
going to uphold in my mind, it's phony.
That is impeachable publicly admitting to
the dereliction of the oath that he swore
to uphold.
You can forget if you want about the first
two and a half years of the Donald Trump presidency
merely based on the last seven days alone.
Donald Trump is impeachable.
It's not clear there are going to be any consequences.
And the next thing I want to talk about when
we listen, if we're going to talk about consequences,
we have to talk about legally issued subpoenas
by a coequal branch of government as enshrined
by the constitution and the rule of law, which
the Trump administration is ignoring and that's
where we need to go next.